hey 42 here the world is full of hidden
wonders and sites that will blow your
mind let's go on a journey to some of
the weirdest places on earth
we start in the weeds
Turkmenistan we're a huge fiery crater
is no to the locals as the door to hell
whilst drilling at the site in 1971
Soviet geologists tapped into an
underground cavern filled with natural
guts but the ground beneath the drilling
rig collapsed leaving a hole 70 meters
in diameter feeling the cavern would
leak poisonous gases the drilling team
decided to burn it off they hoped it
will burn out in a few days but it's
still burning today over 40 years later
next to the u.s. specifically
Yellowstone National Park in Wyoming
here you will find the world's third
largest hot spring and one of the most
beautiful named Grand Prismatic spring
the springs vibrant colors are caused by
its pigmented bacteria seasonal
temperatures as well as levels of
chlorophyll and carotenoids in the
spring greatly influence the tint of its
bacteria and subsequently it's bright
columns bacteria doesn't form in the
center because the water is too hot to
sustain bacterial life Salada a unique
in Bolivia is home to the world's
largest salt flat
occupying the area of roughly 10,000 582
square kilometers
it was created when a prehistoric Lake
dried up and left a salty crust behind
when it rains the entire salt flat
becomes a giant mirror and you can walk
on top of a near-perfect
reflection of the sky in South America
amongst the park ramas mountain range
sits the tabletop mountain mount Roraima
it's one of the oldest
geological formations on earth dating
back over two billion years it serves as
a triple border between brazil venezuela
and guyana it's four hundred meter tall
clips have meant it's been cut off from
human interaction for most of history
subsequently the mountains of a plateau
has its own unique ecosystem understand
thirty percent of all the plant and
animal species are endemic to the
mountain which means they can only be
found on this mountain and nowhere else
on earth but mount Roraima isn't the
only place on earth with an isolated
ecosystem such places are countless but
one of the most interesting is socotra
in yemen which is a small archipelago in
the indian ocean because it's so
isolated one-third of its plant life is
found nowhere else on the planet such as
the dragon's blood trick named after its
blood-red SAP have you ever wanted to
step inside a glacier in SCAF devel
iceland there's an ice cave within
glacier ice this unique cave is a result
of a glacial mill which is a hole inside
a glacier water flows down through the
hole and eventually melts the ice to
form a large cave because glaciers are
constantly moving
if you stand inside the cave you can
hear incredibly loud cracking sounds as
the ice above you under the cave itself
moves millimeters along the ground
from what I see hemisphere to another in
the Antarctic you'll find frozen waves
but these waves are a result of melting
not freezing the downward-pointing
spikes are simply icicles next to China
for the world's most colorful mountain
range the zangi damp ciolan fall in
Gansu this magnificent display of colors
is the result of red sandstone and
mineral deposits being laid down for
over 24
a million years fancy a spot of scuba
diving
the imaginatively names Great Blue Hole
is a popular submarine sinkhole and
scuba diving site just off the coast of
Belize this natural phenomenon is 124
meters deep on vais - island in the
Maldives is the sea of stars beautiful
bioluminescent patterns can be seen
along the shore
these lights are caused by marine
microbes called phytoplankton they
contain a chemical called luciferase
which has the ability to create natural
biological light if you're feeling
romantic you may want to visit the
tunnel of look in clevon ukraine this
hotspot for lovers is an active railway
line engulfed in a tunnel of leaves the
tunnel was formed over many years as a
train which passed through the forest 3
times a day
slowly carved a tunnel through the trees
but natural wonders also come in the
man-made variety such as fly geyser in
Nevada located on the private fly ranch
and cut off and tourists this geyser is
a man-made phenomen created from well
drilling in 1964 while seeking sources
of geothermal energy the well was not
kept correctly undissolved minerals
started rising and accumulating the
mound beneath the geyser is still
growing today and water is constantly
being released also man-made is the
hidden beach in the Marita Islands
Mexico this beautiful secluded beach is
actually the result of bombing the spot
was bombed during target practice by the
Mexican government Chand Bayer II is a
famous stepwell in the Indian state of
Rajasthan it was constructed in 800 CA
Raja Han State is extremely arid under
the intent of de stepwell was to
conserve as much water as possible
during the hot of months the air
he remains five to six degrees cooler at
the bottom compared to the surface
therefore it was commonly used as a
community gathering place for locals
during periods of intense heat thanks
for the view subscribe for more 42
you